Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This paper is from 2007, from ten years ago
and I am sure you'll be surprised by how well
it is still holding up to today's standards.
For me, it was one of the works that foreshadowed
the incredible power of data-driven learning
algorithms.
So, let's grab an image, and cut a sizeable
part out of it, and try to algorithmically
fill it with data that makes sense.
Removing a drunk photobombing friend from
your wedding picture, or a building blocking
a beautiful view to the sea are excellent,
and honestly, painfully real examples of this.
This problem we like to call image completion
or image inpainting.
But mathematically, this may sound like crazy
talk, who really knows what information should
be there in these holes, let alone a computer?
The first question is, why would we have to
synthesize all these missing details from
scratch?
Why not start looking around in an enormous
database of photographs and look for something
similar?
For instance, let's unleash a learning algorithm
on one million images.
And if we do so, we could find that there
may be photographs in the database that are
from the same place.
But then, what about the illumination?
The lighting may be different!
Well, this is an enormous database, so then,
we pick a photo that was taken at a similar
time of the day and use that information!
And as we can see in the results, the technique
works like magic!
Awesome!
It doesn't require user made annotations or
any sort of manual labor.
These results were way, way ahead of the competition.
And sometimes, the algorithm proposes a set
of solutions that we can choose from.
The main challenge of this solution is finding
similar images within the database, and fortunately,
even a trivial technique that we call nearest
neighbor search can rapidly eliminate 99.99%
of the dissimilar images.
The paper also discusses some of the failure
cases, which arise mostly from the lack of
high-level semantic information, for instance,
when we have to finish people, which is clearly
not what this technique is meant to do, unless
it's a statue of a famous person with many
photographs taken in the database.
Good that we're in 2017, and we know that
plenty of research groups are already working
on this, and I wouldn't be surprised to see
a generative adversarial network-based technique
to pop up for this in the very near future.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!